Great. Good afternoon, reinvent.
Uh, I wanna start by
letting you guys in on a little secret.
This is the best one. Many of the fastest
moving companies and engineering
teams in the world don't use GitHub
for code review anymore.
Now what do I mean by that?
What I mean is that they've realized
that this new era of agentic software
development
requires a whole new platform for
code review that can keep up with the pace
at which software can now be written. And that's
exactly what we've built at Graphite.
We are building the AI powered code review platform
for this new age of gente software development.
Well, let's take a quick look at Graphite before we dive in.
Uh, we have, we are privileged
to work with some of the fastest, um,
and largest engineering. Teams in the world,
teams like Shopify, Snowflake, Robinhood,
Duolingo, uh, and it's not
just a matter of hype. We've delivered real
enterprise value for them.
Shopify, for instance, um, after using
Graphite has seen 33%
more PRs merged, uh, per
developer after adopting Graphite.
Asana has shipped 21% more lines
of code per engineer, and we've done this
time and time again with hundreds of thousands of
engineers across the industry.
So before we get into how we do this
exactly, I want to talk about why code review
is important right now and why you can't
just do this, uh, with any AI model.
So starting with the first one, you know, why should we even
care about code review? You know, isn't it enough?
Can't we just let the AI run with this and write
all of our code for us today?
And I, I think that the, the answer to this,
um, if we think about it, is that,
you know, writing code, uh, first of all, how many
of you guys are engineers? Raise your hand if you're,
if you're an engineer. OK, pretty much everybody here.
So, you know, you guys all know that writing code
is only the first part of the story.
You know, once we've written the code, you know, we'll
build it locally, we'll debug.
But after that happens, we still have to
go through the entire out of loop process of
getting our code reviewed, testing it,
you know, reviewing, getting it merged, deploying
it. And oftentimes at enterprise
scale, uh, this is actually more of the
bottleneck than writing it in the first place.
Uh, even before this age of AI,
uh, my co-founders and I all came from large companies
like Meta and Google, where we'd often
spend more time waiting for our co-workers
to give us code reviews than we would actually building
the feature in the first place.
So, Codeview's always been a bottleneck at enterprises,
and this has always been important.
But now, AI is making this 10 times
worse because every engineer has these incredible
tools like quad code, cursor,
you know, Windsurf, that they're able to use
to build features faster than ever.
But again, this is just shifting
this bottleneck over to the right here, like all
of that. That code still needs to be
reviewed. It still needs to be tested, merged,
and deployed.
Uh, and now what we're finding and hearing from many
of our largest customers is that their engineers
are just drowning in PRs. They can't
find enough time in the day
to review the PRs that their teams can
now can now create.
I thought that this tweet really summarized it
well.
The new bottleneck is no longer doing the work,
it's reviewing the work.
So this is our conclusion number one.
This, in this new age of AI codegen
needs AI code review if we're going
to truly unlock the power of LLMs
for generating code.
Put another way,
you can't just apply AI to the
IDE. You kind of need to apply
it to your entire toolchain if you
want to really get the most out of what LLMs
can do for software development.
So, you know, that answers the first question, but,
you know, now you're probably thinking,
why can't we just rely on the base LLMs? Like,
isn't, isn't loud code and GPT
5 good enough on their own to,
to be a reviewer? Like, can't we just hack something
together, throw it in a GitHub action, and, and let
it run?
Well, this was actually the first thing. That we did when
we tried to build this. So, in the
beginning, uh, we started before, uh, before
AI was, was really powerful. Uh, we
were just building a workflow tool, and the
first approach that we had to this when we were experimenting
was, you know, let's just take the code diff
and give it to Claude and see what happens. So,
we tried that.
And these are some of the common responses we get. Things
like, you know, you should update the code to just do what it's
doing already.
You know, CSS doesn't work this way.
You should add a comment here, this is a really common
one, you know, or even you should just revert
this code to do exactly what it used to do.
You know, it's kind of like you just dropped an intern into your
code base in their first week on the job and
expected them to do complicated refactors.
So, this is the second major realization that
we had, was that the LLMs are
trained in RL to generate code in
seconds,
but reviewing and understanding
of code is a much harder problem that
needs a lot of specialized engineering.
Uh, it's an instance of what's called the, the generator
validator gap in LLM research, where
LLMs are fantastic at generating
valid examples of something.
But they're much worse at understanding and, and
validating uh why something
is valid. Like they can't exactly introspect
and tell you, you know, why is this correct, like
why is this matching the pattern that it, that we want it
to. So,
that was the second major realization,
uh, and that really brings us to this 3rd
point, um, and the most interesting question,
you know, how is Graphite achieving
this? Like, how are we helping enterprises ship
code faster in this new era of AI?
And it's a multi-pronged approach.
It's not enough just to drop in an agent
that reviews code, you really need the whole
platform for code review and reimagining
the pull request experience completely end to
end. And that's exactly what we've done.
So, first of all, we have an AI review agent,
uh, that scans every pull request in a few
seconds. It's able to find bugs,
security vulnerabilities, any of the common
issues that a developer would, would be looking for
in a code review, but
instead of waiting potentially hours overnight for
a co-worker to give you a review, this will give
you the review in a few seconds. So, you save
hours of back and forth, what would have been like
many, many review cycles now can
be condensed down into one.
We've combined that though with a best in class
code review experience. So we have an inbox
that unifies your workflow and shows you
exactly what PRs are waiting on your review,
where your changes are in progress.
It's amazing that in, in 10 years, GitHub has
not built a way to just organize your workflow
and see what you need to do.
That's the first thing you see when you log into raftite.
We also bring you smarter self-fueling CI,
so graphite agent will suggest if a test
is failing, uh, it'll suggest a fix,
uh, and, and let you just rerun it, requeue
it, um, and get that unblocked.
We're about to introduce merge conflict resolution
as well. So if, if something is failing
in merge, graphite agent will fix it for you,
uh, get your quick sign off and be ready to
keep going.
Uh, we let you measure developer productivity and
we bring it all together, um, in a
smaller platform.
This is quite a quick view of what, what the new PR page
looks like. Let me see if I can get this to play. So
we basically have, you have your PR, but you
have, uh, a whole chat window right
alongside it, so. In Graphite, I can
ask it questions, I can understand this
change. I can have it highlight a few issues,
and then I can actually have, uh, I can actually give
it an instruction and work with it. So,
in this case, I'm asking graphite agent to swap out
the model. It's gonna actually make that
change in line, propose a code change.
I can open up a whole editor and view the diff
that it's generated,
and then with one click, I can go ahead and apply that
change. Uh, this previously would
have, would have taken you,
minutes or potentially hours to like go back
to your, to your IDE,
make this change, you know, pull the changes in, make
the change, push it back up. Get a
review again.
Now this is all just happening in a matter of seconds
uh on Graphite's new PR page. So, yeah,
much like what Cursor did to VS code and like
bringing AI like right into the
IDE,
we're doing that with pull requests with Graphite, bringing
an agent in real time that you can collaborate with
right into the PR page.
So, graphite agent, yeah, it's not just,
it's not just a matter of, of being there and working
with you. Uh, you know, we can really validate
the results of this, um, and looking at, at
the rate at which it's comments are accepted. So,
You know, less than 4% of graphite agents' comments
are downvoted or marked as, as not accurate,
uh, and 55% of comments actually
then lead to an underlying code change.
This is always how we're measuring and validating
that every change we make to graphite agent or every
change graphite agent suggests is, is a good
one and that you want it to actually lead
to that code being changed.
For comparison, humans are about 49%
here, so we've actually now exceeded,
uh, like graphite agent is now better than the vast
majority of human code reviewers in terms of
the percentage of their comments that actually create
code changes in the end.
frameworks. So,
you know, going back to, uh, going back to the Enterprise
Impact and talking about this, uh, Shopify
has been one of our, our larger customers and
one that's really worked with us and pushed us to,
you know, help their engineering team move as quickly as possible.
Uh, you can imagine in the past month or
two, they were in their full sprint, getting
ready for Black Friday and Cyber Monday. It's
a huge, huge code push for them. Uh,
you know, they're doing, they're doing like tens of thousands
of PRs and lead up to this, uh.
And with Graphite, uh, we saw real
results in terms of developer efficiency. So
33% more PR shipped per engineer.
Uh, we're now up to, uh, almost
three quarters of all PRs, um, at Shopify
are now being merged through Graphite instead
of GitHub.
Um, again, hundreds of thousands of PRs that this is
covered, and, you know, if you, if you want to really
dig into like what is the enterprise impact of this,
uh, we get to, you know, hundreds of
additional engineers' worth of developer time
saved. You know, you can imagine every single PR,
even if you're saving an hour or two off of, off
of review time, off of time that they would have been blocked
waiting for somebody to unblock them.
That's a huge amount of time over an entire
year, uh, and a huge amount of engineering
hours that you're now giving back to the team and,
uh, letting them spend less time in review and
more time doing what matters and actually being able
to build.
We're, you know, zooming out. We're really excited,
uh, and, and we're proud to partner with some
of the leading companies in the industry. So, you
know, Robinhood, we talked about Shopify, but, you
know, Robinhood, Snowflake,
teams like RAM, some of the AI native companies
like Harvey and Replet and Purcell, uh,
really seeing across the industry, uh, like
large adoption of this and, uh, excitement
around what AI can do again, not just
in the IDE but in the outer loop as
a whole.
You know, back to the graph I did a glance, you know,
what we've built is the best in class code review platform
on top of GitHub.
We're trusted by some of the very best
developers and teams in the industry, um, and
we're really bringing AI to, uh, to the
pull request process and transforming what
code review looks like now, um, in this new era
of software development.
So, a few key takeaways that I want to leave you with.
Uh, number one, you know, LLMs
are really flooding enterprise engineering teams
with more code than they can safely review.
We now have, you know, not only is there more
code being generated than ever, uh, we see
about 70% more,
more code per engineer, uh, now
than we saw back in 2023. Um,
it's just a huge amount of more, more changes
that are being created, uh, with the help of LLMs
now. So,
there's more code.
It's also less, you know, potentially like
less valid, uh, less safe code
than ever before because, you know, let's be real, is
every single engineer scanning every line
that's being generated?
Probably not. Like they're putting, they're in a rush, they're putting
code up, you know, we almost need, you
know, not only just to handle the volume of
code, uh, but the nature of AI generated
code, you know, necessitates us to have
better tooling around making sure that it's reviewed,
making sure that it's safe, and making sure that it's validated.
So, there's more code than ever before. We
need AI code review more than ever.
You know, traditional tools and LLMs, we
can't just take quad code or or
GBT-5 and throw it at this and expect it to
do well. We really need a whole
new platform for code review for this new era.
Um, and that's exactly what we've delivered. You know, Graphite
has, has built that platform. We've integrated
AI into the entire pull request life cycle
from the moment it's created to the moment that it's merged,
uh, and we're delivering, you know, really great
measurable enterprise outcomes, um, by doing
that. Uh,
thank you guys very much. That's all I've got for you. Uh,
you can find us. We're on graphite.com if
you wanna check it out. Uh, you can try the platform
out for free, uh, for 30 days.
Um, and we're right around the corner, um, over
at Booth 535 if you wanna come
check us out. Uh, we got plenty of people who can tell you
more about the platform and the details, and, uh,
we're excited to chat with you. So thank you very much,
everyone. Thank you.